the response I got from the last video
was far beyond what I was expecting the
comments were great and offered both
recommendations and suggestions for
future videos I'd like to thank everyone
for the kind words and hopefully I can
follow up with some videos that you find
just as useful the next couple of videos
will be an extension of the previous
video where I'll go into a little bit
more depth around the build types that
are mentioned this video will cover the
solo build I'll run you through the
thought process and everything you
should be considering when making this
built we'll be focusing on the nomad set
as this is the set that was developed
mainly for solo play and the bonuses it
provides really do help keep you alive
or learning the basic mechanics of the
game for this reason I see this it is
probably the best beginners set in the
game while you're still mastering the
movement and learning how to react in
certain situations the set is by far the
most forgiving if you make any mistakes
particularly if you're running solo but
the basics I'll be talking about here
can definitely be taken away and used
with other sets that you choose to use
I'm not a huge fan of 40-minute videos
that provide around 5 minutes of actual
information so I'll be trying to keep
this video as concise and informative as
possible if you require more information
on anything I mentioned or a breeze over
anything to lightly let me know in the
comments and I'll try and expand on it
further as per usual I'll be adding a
cheat sheet or quick reference guide to
the end of this video that will sum up
everything discussed here
before we get into the building want to
talk about the ninja bike messenger bag
this exotic backpack was introduced to
the game with a hugely underwhelming
unique bonus it was the joke among
exotics over time all of the exotics
have been tweaked in one way or another
but the ninja bike got a complete revamp
as of patch 1.7 the ninja bike messenger
bag new bonus is slots in with any
equipped gear set to fulfill a
requirement towards unlocking a gear
sets bonus can unlock bonuses from
multiple sets simultaneously essentially
this makes the ninja bike a sort of
wildcard force it's it's able to fulfill
a set bonus requirement with the
potential to provide this requirement
for multiple gear sets at the same time
for example if you had three pieces of
Nomad two pieces of technicians and the
ninja bike equipped the ninja bike will
count as both the fourth piece of nomads
and the third piece of technicians
unlocking the fourth and third piece
bonus in each set note the ninja bike
cannot be used to apply the five or six
piece bonus with classified pieces
basically this exotic item opens up a
huge number of build options and if you
don't have one yet do your best to find
one in a way it opens you up to the next
tier of build options knowing full well
that a number of you won't have one of
these yet I'll be showing two versions
of this build one with the ninja bike
bag and one without
as I mentioned in the last video these
builds will be focused around PvE the
first thing you might notice is that I
have four pieces of classified Nomad
because of the stash size and the sheer
number of items in the game I don't have
the space for non classified gear but
the only difference between these and
the normal gear sets in this situation
is the stats are slightly higher so it's
still a fairly close indication of the
numbers you'll be achieving this is
quite a DPS heavy version of the Nomad
build if your finding itself a little
too squishy I'd recommend changing it
another one of the main pieces into
stamina here we have four piece Nomad a
specialized backpack and savage gloves
the Nomad set is the backbone to this
build it offers health on kill constant
heal and essentially an extra life if
you get taken down the savage gloves
assist with your damage output giving
you a 7% increase in critical hit chance
against targets out of cover the
specialized backpack adds 200% review
firearms and stamina to skill power this
might seem a bit strange adding a skill
power focus gear piece to a
predominantly toughness and firearms
build but I've done this for a couple of
reasons one at this stage of the game
there really isn't too many useful high
end gear talents out there and two I'm a
big fan of skills regardless of build
type they heavily assist my style of
play and the specialized backpack can
give a pretty decent buff to your skill
power when you have mainly firearms and
stamina three of the pieces have been
rolled into firearms as their main stat
and two into stamina if you're finding
yourself a little squishy you could try
running three pieces with stamina damage
to elites is a must for PvE builds so
this has been rolled into the mask and
kneepads
enemy armor damage is also one of the
go-to PvE attributes you should be going
for this has been rolled into the chest
mask and knee pads ammo capacity has
been rolled onto the chest and backpack
particularly good for those high rate of
fire weapons ammo capacity is what we
like to call a quality of life perk
you'll thank me later for this one on
the backpack you'll see overall skill
power as the major attribute when
another option in the slot could be
extra health and with the sort of build
focusing on sustainability it would make
more sense to go for health right well
let's say we rolled 13,000 into health
instead this would increase our
toughness from four hundred and three
thousand to four hundred and twenty
three thousand this gives us an increase
in toughness of less than five percent
if we gave 13 thousand and two skill
it would increase from 121 thousand to a
hundred and thirty four thousand giving
us an increase in skill power of just
under ten percent even if we rounded it
up to five percent this really isn't too
much of an increase in toughness
especially when we could be instead
providing an even larger increase to the
intensity and frequency of our skills of
which we are likely to be using at least
one healing ability which will further
increase our sustainability this is
really just a small taste of how in
depth you can go with your builds and
really optimize each slot to your style
of play at the end of the day whether it
be health or skill power really isn't
gonna make or break the build I'm just
trying to show a different way of
thinking when you're deciding on what
you should roll into each piece anyway
the gloves have fairly standard roles
assault rifle damage critical hit chance
and critical hit damage assault rifle
damage should be changed to whatever
weapon type you using as your primary
critical hit damage could be replaced
for enemy armor damage either will work
well skill hast has been rolled onto the
chest and holster skill haste helps get
your skills back faster by reducing the
cooldown you could instead role critical
hit chance on the holster if you'd like
a little bit more damage
here we're running three-piece Nomad
2-piece printers mark and the ninja buck
messenger bag with the ninja bike we
gain the four piece Nomad and the three
piece Predators market bonuses the three
piece Predators mark gives you a plus
ten percent reload speed and a plus
eight percent assault rifle and SMG
damage combined these give quite a good
boost to the amount of damage you can do
over time without the ninja bike you'd
only be gaining the two piece predators
mark bonus plus temps entry load speed
and this alone really isn't worth
trading in the savage gloves and
specialized backpack for not an
impressive build but stick into the
Nomad theme of this video it gives you a
good idea of what the ninja bike can do
for you and the types of sets you can
start mixing together instead of
predators mark you may choose to use
something like 2-piece technicians which
will balance out your build a bit
providing a bit more in the way of skill
power and skill haste
the weapons are up to you use whatever
you feel comfortable with games of this
nature will always have a meter but as
of 1.8 there really isn't such a huge
gap between the current meter the
lightweight in for and anything else you
choose to use more important is picking
a weapon with the right attributes most
of my builds will either use an m4
variant of the assault rifle or an SMG
as I prefer the higher rate of fire
weapons as my primary here I'm using a
light weighting forward due to the
gloves I'm wearing plus 12 cent assault
rifle damage but a Nissen view would
work too because this build is quite
capable of getting up close and personal
the main difference between in pours and
SMGs would be the SMGs have better
handling but require you to be a little
bit closer than assault rifles because
of the damage drop off the talents I've
chosen are predatory killing a target
regenerates 35% health over 20 seconds
responsive damage is increased by 10%
when closer than 10 meters to the target
and unforgiving missing health segments
increase your damage predatory will
further increase health on kill
responsive and unforgiving for an
increase in damage
unforgiving which quite well with nomads
because you can really push the limits
of your health bar due to the constant
healing and the fact that the full piece
bonus will pick you up if you do leave
it a bit too late there are a bunch of
other talents that will work quite well
with us-built - but I definitely try to
at least get predatory if you can it's
one of the most helpful talents in the
game when it comes to sustainability in
PvE
the modernist weapon are mainly around
aiding boats critical hit chance and
damage and a little bit of stability if
you are running an SMG instead I'd focus
on all critical hit damage as smg's come
with a high amount of base critical hit
chance and are quite easy to handle I
usually like to have a ranged weapon as
my secondary so I can keep my options
open
particularly when running solar plus I'm
a big fan of sniping the headshot sound
in this game never gets old but you may
choose instead to run with another close
to medium combat weapon
the skills are booster shot and tactical
pulse booster shot will give you a small
heal but the main reason for running
this is a 15% weapon damage and 7.5%
damage resistance tactical pulse will
further increase your damage output in
the way of critical hit chance and
damage but will also help you be a bit
more aware of the enemies around you if
you're going to be venturing into the
dark zone for a bit of farming make sure
you change out the tactical pulse for a
scrambler pulse this will help keep you
a little more hidden from other players
talents are critical save strike back
and on the move these will assist with
survivability and precision for another
increase in damage
I'm running firearms damage to elite
mods don't be put off by the fact these
are purple mods the main stat is a
little lower than the golds but the
damage to elites bonus is huge in PvE
keep an eye on the vendors each week I'd
recommend stocking up on firearms
stamina and electronics damage to elite
mods while a minute bookmark this page
Ruben and his team do an awesome job for
the community each week they run around
to each vendor on the map recording
what's for sale I'll leave a link in the
description for the performance mods
that recommend first-aid self heal these
will just help you get a little bit more
out of your first-aid skill
the key to this build as it's currently
set up is as long as you're getting
kills your stay at alive you have a
decent amount of health I'm killed with
the set and predatory on your weapon
the damage to elites enemy armor damage
and damage dealing perks on your weapon
will be more than enough to quickly drop
most enemies health or kill along with a
four piece set bonus that Nomad gives
allows you to be a bit more reckless
with your playstyle the most difficult
content will require you to utilize more
cover as you probably won't be able to
drop the enemies as quickly as they can
focus you down this is a solid robust
set at any skill level but be careful
with becoming too reliant on the four
piece bonus it can make things difficult
for you when you choose to transition to
other builds
you shouldn't have any problems running
this built through challenging missions
underground HV TS and dark zone farming
you can even try it out on the legendary
Times Square mission but I probably
wouldn't recommend it you'll have a
rough time it's also not really suited
for resistance
I ran the non ninja bike version solo
and managed to open a couple of the
resistance just gaining a couple of
classified pieces but it was pretty
tough in the next video I plan on
talking about skill power builds these
are pretty fun and once you've gained a
bit of experience with being able to
keep yourself alive you'll be able to
tackle some of the more difficult
content with the massive damage you can
get out of your skills anyway if this
has helped in some way please let me
know I'm pretty keen to keep this going
as a series but obviously only if people
are finding it useful thanks again for
all the feedback and I'll see you in the
next video Cheers
you
don't like the looks of this
[Music]